[Music]
christian
aguilar is calling out to the wolves
about 35 mexican gray wolves or
lobos live in this area in the state of
chihuahua
[Music]
aguilara is involved in a project to
re-establish and grow
populations of the mexican wolf
orcharnes lupus ballet
to give it its scientific name they are
shy creatures
it's hard to spot any here in the sierra
madre occidental mountain range
which extends over almost 2 million
hectares
but aguilar says the evidence indicates
some are nearby
here we see several sets of footprints
so the wolves could still be here
this shows that they're alive and
looking for food
aguilar checks one of the camera traps
the photos confirm what he suspected
wow wow wow
there are a couple of young wolves
they're looking good
healthy and behaving normally
this camera only takes still photos
others record video aguilar is pleased
these wolves look well fed
that's good news the mexican gray wolf
is an endangered species he says the
composition of their feces is also a
good sign
wild turkeys are among the animals lobos
hunt in the wild
along with deer squirrels rats and
peccaries
aguilar will examine samples of wolf
feces in the lab
he says the hairs probably come from a
deer or a peccary
so it looks like the wolves here have
plenty to eat
that means the wolves won't hunt cattle
and that should help resolve the
conflict with the cattle ranchers
[Music]
ranchers and landowners had almost
killed off the mexican wolf
its natural habitat used to extend from
the southern united states to southern
mexico
dozens of organizations in the two
countries have got together to
re-establish populations in the wild
of robust animals with enough genetic
diversity
to be genetically viable
eduardo payan is one of the few ranchers
around here
who would welcome more wolves
he's even made his land available to the
project
two wolves will be released here in a
few days time
while his father used to hunt wolves he
says the environment would benefit if
they returned
and took their rightful place in the
ecosystem
they're an important link in the food
chain
the advantage for cattle ranchers would
be that wolves would displace the
coyotes
they don't really belong in this
ecosystem wolves are competition for
them and would drive them away
because wolves are the natural predators
here on the ranch
wolves often leave remains of their prey
behind
providing food for scavenger species
wolves also help maintain the health of
the cattle
because they tend to attack sick and
weakened animals
christian aguilar regularly visits
ranchers
and tries to convince them of the
advantages of having wolves in the area
it's no easy task especially when wolves
have been spotted within 200 meters
as happened here
we live off our animals so we have to
look after them
we have to protect ourselves from any
predators that jeopardize our livelihood
and that often means with guns
[Music]
aguilar tells ranchers that under
certain conditions
they will receive compensation if a wolf
kills livestock
he also points out that wolves don't
normally like to have cattle for dinner
while pumas and coyotes certainly do
and they in turn tend to move away from
areas where wolves live
at the buena vista de cobra wildlife
facility
in the neighboring state of sonora 11
wolves are being prepared for their
return to the wild
today's exercise hunting wild turkeys
brought into the enclosure especially
for the purpose
veterinarian fausto armenta tries to
observe the hunt from a distance
so we can evaluate their behavior and
their hunting skills
these wolves are about to be released
into the wild
and we want to stimulate their hunting
instinct with
live prey
to survive in the wild they have to be
good hunters
it's important that as the wolves hunt
they can neither see nor smell
people nearby
i'm looking for them but i can't see
them and that's a good thing
it means they've run away from us
the wolves shouldn't assume people will
continue to provide them with food
they need to fend for themselves
and it looks like they already are to
judge by these turkey remains
back on payan's ranch in chihuahua the
time has come to set
two wolves free a male and a female
they leave their human carers and are
now on their own
they can join a pack or have pups and
start one of their own
you